[Musik]
es ist die größte Mobilisierung des
israelischen Militärs seit Jahrzehnten
über 300.000 Reservisten wurden
eingezogen Konvois transportierten heute
Panzer und Artillerie an die Grenzen zum
Gazastreifen und zum Libanon den Angriff
der Hamas vor zwei Tagen beantwortet die
Armee auch heute mit weiteren
Luftangriffen mit vielen
und
verlzten der israelische
Verteidigungsminister kündigt eine
vollständige Blockade des
gaserastreifens
an herzlich willkommen zu einem weiteren
ZDF Spezial wieso verschiebt sich um ca
Minuten Israels Antwort auf den Angriff
wird den Nahen Osten verändern kündigte
Premierminister Netanyahu heute an mit
maximaler Härte will Israel gegen den
Terror der Hamas vorgehen noch immer
sitzt der Schock tief und die Sorge ist
groß vor allem um die über 100 Geiseln
die nach Gaza verschleppt wurden viele
der entführten hatten zuvor sorglos auf
einem Musikfest gefeiert Lukas
Eiler
drohenaufnahmen vom Festivalgelände das
Ausmaß des Massakers wird nun deutlich
ausgebrannte Autowracks umgekippte
Fahrzeuge die am Samstag vor den
Terroristen der Hamas geflüchtet waren
ein israelischer Rettungsdienst Zelt 260
getötete
ein elektrofestival in der Wüste nahe
dem Kibo Reim wenige Kilometer vom
Gazastreifen entfernt hier hatten
hunderte junge Menschen bis in die Nacht
getanzt am frühen samstagmgen wurde das
Gelände dann von Hamas Terroristen
überfallen eine Augenzeugin berichtet
von den bewaffneten
Männern und sie waren plötzlich überall
um mich herum sie gingen Baum für Baum
entlang und schossen Pam Pam Pam überall
von beiden Seiten und ich sah viele
Menschen die überall um mich herum
starben ihr gelang die Flucht doch mehr
als 100 Menschen wurden nach
israelischen Angaben in den Gazastreifen
verschleppt viele davon waren
Festivalbesucher gestern Abend finden
sich die Eltern vermisst Israeli
zusammen eine Pressekonferenz live
übertragen im israelischen Fernsehen
auch
merf Tochter war auf dem
Festival Uhr an und sagte Mama wir
wurden bombardiert wurden beschossen und
ich sagte wir haben dich lieb und es ist
okay wir versuchen einen Weg zu finden
dich darauszuholen wir schicken Leute
und ich weiß dass ich gelogen habe weil
wir keine Antworten haben und wir hatten
keine Antworten niemand hatte
welche bei vielen Israeli werden die
Erinnerungen wach an den israelischen
Soldaten gilat schalid 2006 entführte
ihn die Hamas hielt ihn 5 Jahre in Gaza
gefangen bis er 2011 gegen mehr als 1000
in Israel inhaftierte Palästinenser
ausgetauscht
wurde in Israel stellen sich nun viele
die Frage ob und zu welchem Preis die
Gefangenen befreit werden
können ja und in Israel spreche jetzt
mit dem deutschen Botschafter vor Ort
Steffen Seibert guten
Abend guten Abend was mE man denn über
die Situation der Geiseln in Gaza
darunter sollen ja auch deutsche
sein ja man weiß leider sehr sehr wenig
und das macht natürlich die Situation
für die Angehörigen in dieser
Ungewissheit noch viel grausamer wir
sprechen viel mit den Familien es sind
ja auch Familien von israelischdeutschen
doppelstaatlern dabei die nicht wissen
ob ihre Angehörigen jetzt dorthin
verschleppt wurden und wenn ich ehrlich
bin wir können ihnen nicht viel Trost
geben wir können nur sagen und das ist
so dass unsere deutschen Behörden sehr
eng mit den israelischen Behörden
zusammenarbeiten im Kontakt stehen ähm
das ist es natürlich diplomatische
Bemühungen gibt auf Umwege über
vielleicht auf Hamas einzuwirken dass
sie diese Menschen freilassen denn das
muss ganz klar die Forderung sein diese
entführten müssen menschenwürdig
behandelt und so schnell wie möglich
freigelassen werden mhm wie nehmen sie
Israel gerade war zwei Tage nach den
beispiellosen
Angriffen ich nehme Israel als ein sehr
tief verwundetes Land war aber auch als
ein ganz geeintes und fest entschlossen
Land was es an internem Streit und
zerwissenheit in Israel gab und das war
ja gewaltig seit Januar jede Woche diese
Demonstrationen von 100usenden das ist
nicht verschwunden aber es tritt in den
Hintergrund der Zulauf zum Militär sie
haben das gezeigt der ist gewaltig
Rechte linke sekulare religiöse
wollen jetzt ihr Land verteidigen auch
viele Gegner der Besatzung übrigens sind
eingerückt und zu den Waffen
gegangen weil sie sagen das ist nicht
Befreiungskampf was hab Master macht das
ist nackter menschenverachtender Terror
wie wir ih eigentlich nur vom
islamischen Staat kennen und das darf
kein Teil der Zukunft dieser Region sein
jetzt geht es um die Verteidigung des
Kernlands Israel und seiner Bevölkerung
und da steht dieses Land zusammen und
ich finde bewundernswert zusammen mhm es
heißt ja immer die Sicherheit Israels
gehöre für Deutschland zur sogenannten
staatsresung was bedeutet das eigentlich
ganz konkret jetzt in diesem
Fall also ich finde dieser Satz stimmt
heute genauso wie 2008 als die damalige
Bundeskanzlerin Merkel in der Knesset
ausgesprochen hat was heißt er jetzt
konkret vor allem denke ich dass wir
eindeutig sind dass wir ganz eindeutig
sagen israel hat das Recht sich gegen
diesen barbarischen Terror zu
verteidigen dieses Recht hat jeder Staat
Hamas ist eine Terrororganisation auch
da müssen wir ganz klar und eindeutig
sein und sie sind hier vorgegangen genau
wie der islamische Staat vor einigen
Jahren gegen die Jesiden äh da gibt es
keine Rechtfertigung aus dem
israelisch-palästinensischen Konflikt im
Gegenteil Hamas wirft die Sache einer
politischen Beilegung dieses Konflikts
die sich ja viele internationale Partner
Israels unter anderem auch Deutschland
wünschen würden wirft diese Sache weit
zurück wer im palästinensischen Namen
Kinder vor den Augen ihrer Eltern
abschlachtet oder alte Frauen entführt
und sie triumphierend durch die Straßen
von Gaza führt äh der kann sich nicht
Befreiungskämpfer nennen und ich glaube
das klar zu benennen und jetzt
Solidarität mit Israel zu zeigen das
steckt auch in diesem Satz drin mhm
würde es denn auch militärische
Unterstützung geben bei
Anfrage das steht jetzt überhaupt nicht
zur Debatte eine solche Anfrage gibt es
nicht die Israelis äh tun jetzt das was
sie glauben tun zu müssen äh und das ist
ein Vorgehen gegen diamas im
Gazastreifen und wir können nur hoffen
äh dass es sich nicht in die ganze
Region ausweitet der Bundeskanzler die
Außenministerin haben ja zurecht davor
gewarnt dass jetzt andere terrorakteure
in der Region beispielsweise hisbolla in
Libanon auf die Idee kämen sich den
Terroraktionen der hermass anzuschließen
das wäre ein Flächenbrand das wäre ein
Zweifrontenkrieg für Israel und
natürlich eine katastrophale
Verschlechterung dieser ohnehin schon
schlechten Situation vielen Dank für die
Einschätzung dem deutschen Botschafter
in Israel steefen
seIber Dank
hören die Hamas hat mit ihrem Terror
offenelegt wie angreifbar israel ist der
Schlag traf das Land unerwartet und
unvorbereitet zu einem Zeitpunkt in dem
Israel im Streit über die Justizreform
tief gespalten war und Reservisten
öffentlich mit dienstverweigerung
drohten über die Lage in Israel Andreas
Stamm vom Erwachen aus einer Illusion
sprechen manche dass man in Israel
umgeben von Feinden trotzdem irgendwie
sicher sei Militär und Geheimdiensten
sei Dank nun hunderte tote Zivilisten
Kampfhandlungen auf israelischem Boden
nicht nur Raketenbeschuss in telaviv
organisieren die Menschen spenden für
alle Israelis in Not und das schließt
jetzt sogar das Militär mit
ein wir tun alles damit unsere Soldaten
kämpfen können alle
zivilgesellschaftlichen Gruppen kommen
hier zusammen an einer Stelle um mit
allem zu unterstützen was nötig
ist wie konnte das als und allzeit
bereit bezeichnete Militär so überrascht
werden eine These seit Monaten
protestieren hunderttausende gegen die
Justizreform der rechtsreligiösen
Regierung Netanyahu die sich mit
unkontrollierter Machtfülle ausstatten
wolle unter den Demonstranten auch
tausende Reservisten bis hin zu
Kampfpiloten einem Baustein der
Landesverteidigung die im Juli erklären
sie wollen nicht mehr zum Dienst
erscheinen ich glaube was man sagen kann
ist dass die Polarisierung in Israel die
auch auch Teile des Militärs betroffen
hat tatsächlich Auswirkungen haben auf
das funktionieren auf das
Zusammenarbeiten wir haben das in
Analysen von Seiten der Hamas und ihrer
Verbündeten in der letzten Zeit immer
wieder gehört dass der Eindruck
entstanden ist Israel sei jetzt sehr
stark geschwächt und vielleicht auch
überheblich so Experten der vor zwei
Jahren fertiggestellte Grenzzaun zum
Gazastreifen lasse der Hamas keine
Option rühmte sich die Politik Beton und
Sensoren wiegten in Sicherheit die
Bedrohung käme eher aus dem ebenfalls
besetzten Westjordanland tatsächlich
waren große Teile der Kräfte eben in der
Westbank gebunden
aufgrund der Anschläge die ja in den
letzten anderthalb Jahren im Nachgang
der Auseinandersetzung von
2021 eben aus der Westbank gekommen sind
die Hamas in Gaza verhielt sich in all
der Zeit ruhig eine trügerische Stille
in der selbst was kaum einer glauben
kann dem israelischen
geheimdienstapparat entging was sich da
zusammenbraute und dann schalten wir
noch mal nach Israel zu unserem
Korrespondenten Michael beberung in
Aschkelon guten Abend Michael warum
konnte Israel so unvorbereitet
überrumpelt
werden da gibt es zahlreiche
Spekulationen aber eigentlich keine
genauen Antworten eine Spekulation ist
dass es kurz vor dem Angriff der Hamas
eine Cyberattacke gegeben hat diesen
extrem hochmodernen digitalisierten
Sicherheitszaun mit seinen ganzen
Sensoren außer Kraft gesetzt hat eine
zweite Antwort ist dass dieser Anschlag
in Wahrheit von lange Hand von Iran
gesteuert und vorbereitet war weil auch
die hamaskämpfer gar nicht die Logistik
und die Manpower gehabt hätten einen
solchen Angriff koordiniert
durchzuführen Iran streitet das ab
darüber hinaus bleibt aber die Frage
selbst wenn diese Sicherungsmechanismen
versagt haben warum gab es keinerlei
Truppen vor Ort die sich den Kämpfern
der Hamas entgegengestellt haben dafür
gibt es Berichte dass ein Großteil der
Truppen wegen der jüngsten Spannung im
Westjordanland war und quasi abgezogen
war also es gibt insgesamt viele
Spekulationen aber noch keine konkrete
Antwort aber das ist die große Frage die
im Hintergrund steht und die wenn sich
hier erstmal die größten Probleme gelegt
haben und vielleicht auch erst diese
große Offensive vorbei ist erst danach
behandelt werden wird ja israel hat ja
angekündigt nur eine Rache zu üben was
erwarten Sie in den nächsten
Tagen ja das ist leider ein ganz klares
Motiv auge um Auge Zahn um Zahn es soll
Rache geübt werden das ist sicherlich
auch ein Teil der Bombenangriffe auch
wenn immer wieder betont wird dass die
Israelis versuchen würden militärische
Ziele der Hamas zu treffen äh im Moment
sind glaube ich das was wir an
Raketenangriffen z.B hier auf die Stadt
askelon und israelische Städte oder die
Bomben die im Moment auf Gasa regnen nur
der Auftag zu einer großen Schlacht das
ist die große
Bodenoffensive und eigentlich lassen
keine regierungsquellen Zweifel daran
dass es zu dieser Offensive kommt es
gibt Spekulation dass schon in Tagen
soweit sein könnte wir haben hier auch
im Süden Aufmarsch von Panzern und
Geschützen gesehen die Dörfer die vorher
von der Amas angegriffen worden sind
müssten dann von den Bewohnern evakuiert
werden die sind teilweise in Hotels in
Jerusalem am Toten Meer untergebracht
das gleiche gilt übrigens für den Norden
also Israel stellt sich auf einen großen
frontenkrieg an möglicherweise auf einen
zweif Fronten oder noch mehr
frontenkrieg ja israel hat ja heute auch
Ziel im Süden Libanons angegriffen
vielleicht noch ganz kurz welche
Auswirkung hat das jetzt für die gesamte
Region momentan noch keine nach meiner
Einschätzung sind das eher heute
Palästinenser gewesen und keine
lebanisische
hzbollah es kam auch nur zu kleineren
Gefechten das ist noch keine Eröffnung
einer zweiten Front die droht
möglicherweise aber dann würden die
Gefechte ganz anders aussehen vielen
dank Michael beberunge nach
aschkalon ja das war unser ZDF Spezial
am Tag 3 nach Beginn der beispiellosen
Angriffe mehr dazu jederzeit auf ZDF
heute und dann später im heute journal
hier geht es jetzt weiter mit Viso und
Markus nihes auf
[Musik]
Wiedersehen